este es el primer barco que está listo
para partir de puertos ucranianos este
es el puerto de odessa y este barco
tiene una historia bastante particular
tiene bandera panameña ya había llegado
a territorio ucraniano el 22 de febrero
dos días antes de la invasión rusa lo
estaban terminando de cargar en el
momento en que empezaron los ataques y
desde entonces está aquí lo han
protegido pero se ha quedado cargado con
país desde entonces en este momento
tiene completa gasolina la tripulación
está lista para zarpar en el momento que
les den el visto bueno sin embargo la
gran pregunta sigue llegando desde moscú
tiene que garantizar la salida de estos
barcos y la seguridad para atravesar
todo el mar hasta llegar a turquía esto
todavía no se conoce no se conoce el
camino que pueden atravesar así que
están a la espera pero en el momento en
el que les digan se van este barco
partirá